video is sponsored by keeps which means
we'll hear more from them somewhere in
the middle of the video hello beautiful
people I'm Alana and I do monthly gaming
q and A's here on my gaming channel I do
a q a about everything else on my other
channel links in the description and
today we got a whole lot of questions
about summer game Fest including some
questions about some of the games that I
got to see a little bit more of or play
Hey Alana who do you think won this
year's E3 it's on the game first but
it's easy to call it E3 I get it I
definitely know my answer but curious
how you would rank the conferences uh
yeah so I didn't get time to watch all
of them obviously because a lot of them
take place during my work hours which is
Obama and there's not enough time off
the work to catch up on all of them
there were a lot but I can tell you of
the ones that I did watch I definitely
think
the Xbox conference was very strong
and if I can separate it I would say I
think the best presentation that we got
was the Starfield direct a lot of detail
very well paced not too many people just
standing and talking Ubisoft and I went
from previously being like look I don't
doubt this game is going to be
impressive but I'm not totally sure if
it's for me because I've said this a
million times and I'm a very big Fallout
person I'm slightly less of an eldest
girls person so for Star Fields before
the director was like I don't know
if this is going to be one of the ones
for me that I'm like oh my God I'm
obsessed I did really love the outer
worlds and I do love no man's sky and if
you think those games don't have
anything in common you're a big dumb
dummy that's it I said it they have
things in common it's it's just an
objective truth there's nothing wrong
with it no man's sky is amazing these
days but I came away being incredibly
impressed we're kind of in a weird
landscape now where I don't know that
you can take everything that people put
into these conferences as like 100
guaranteed to be in the game and I
always just try to like take that with a
grain of salt that maybe as development
continues some things have to get cut
because scope so I just always try to
keep that in the back of my head and
don't let myself get too carried away
with excitement especially because I
felt like I had that with um Fallout 76
where I was very very excited and it
didn't turn out to be quite what I
hugged and I know I'm not alone then so
with the grain of salt uh I am now
extremely excited about Starfield I
think it looks incredible and the thing
that gets me is there's stuff about it
that doesn't appeal to me but it seems
like I don't have to do those things
um I've never liked in really any game
uh space combat dog fighting I've really
never enjoyed in any game where you have
two ships in space and they fly around
and try and shoot each other it's just
never been my thing so when they said
that you could instead of board ships
like mid-space
um mind blown yes I will be doing that I
will be doing some space piracy thank
you but yeah my point is like it seems
like they gave us so much information
and there are things that we can do and
things that we cannot do depending on
your play style like in theory if you're
interested in the pods that are a lot
more like no man's sky and less
interested in the Bethesda RPG I think
you could just like not play the
Bethesda RPG and just mine resources on
weird planets and build a giant base and
I love that for me I'm so into that I
guess depending on the level of
technicality it looks pretty simple
there are some games where like building
is is doesn't appeal to me I loved it in
no man's sky so yeah that was my
highlight for sure was um the Starfield
direct and then it would be the Xbox
showcase I did say beforehand that I
didn't want to see Fable unless it was
gameplay and close and I think that
still stands excited that it continues
to exist I think having
um Richard iowati
be a part of it is a great pick the tone
seems right but that's really all I was
able to actually get from Fable
obviously it looks massively different
it should it's several years uh since
the last game and it's a totally
different Studio that all makes sense
but we didn't see a side of it that
makes me any more excited about
favorable anymore sure that I will like
it I love Fable particularly the Lost
Chapters I presume that I will like the
new one but I don't know I don't love
Fable 203 anywhere near as much as I
love the first game so still glad it
exists not necessarily what I wanted to
see from it I kind of feel like maybe
they should have held off a little
longer but I feel like I'm probably like
very alone in that take was also nice to
see what compulsion games is working on
even if we kind of have no idea what it
is and hellblade 2 I'm hyped about no
matter what I love Ninja Theory I love
hellblade I'm very excited about that
game that was another one that I was
like okay you don't need to show us at
this point just give us the game but I
love the pacing of the Xbox show I feel
like there was some good variety they're
very very strong clearly on the RPG
front which is awesome thoughts all
looks beautiful
um yeah lots of good stuff in it third
in line would be summer game first
itself uh the Keeley showcase as it were
I just feel like it was it was mostly
really good um it was just a bit too
long there was kind of a lull in the
middle and when I say the middle I think
it was a lull of like an hour or so not
to say none of those games look good I
just feel like there's maybe a thing in
2023 where a lot of games and they're
either having trouble with marketing or
we just have a lot of the same games a
lot of the games started to look very
very similar um that I think I'd have
trouble remembering a lot of their names
a lot of the characters the protagonists
even started seem very similar it just
kind of became a bit of a mess yeah I
don't know if that's like are they all
Outsourcing to the same marketing
Studios to make their trailers I don't
know but they were uh unfortunately just
a few things in there that looked
generic which sucks because I'm sure
that they aren't just that their
trailers were after that I would put the
other two that I watched for Capcom and
Ubisoft right oh wait wait no devolver
is definitely not devolver was
incredible the developer conference is
incredible every year
um honestly I'd give it like top marks
AAA Plus but not that many games and
some games that had been revealed before
but the whole presentation was amazing
obviously this is so good little
skill up Cameo I would have thought it
was incredible so then probably Capcom
some good games but it was a bit of a
weird conference especially considering
how recently they just had a conference
um they just weren't
enough updates I think to really warrant
the conference it was just a bit of a
weird one I love Capcom and what they're
doing right now I think they're doing
incredible work right now Capcom of
killing it on so many fronts just not a
lot of substance in that conference
still like the pacing though was uh glad
to see a little bit more Dragons Dogma
too but it wasn't as much as they would
have liked to have seen it is time to
talk about keeps which is a subscription
service that helps men keep their hair
before I even agreed to start working
with keeps many years ago at this point
I spoke to many friends who use them and
across the board everybody encouraged me
to tell you all about keeps in case
boldness is a concern that you have or
something that is slowly happening to
you of course it's absolutely nothing to
be ashamed of just letting you know
there's an option available if this is
something you're interested in so in
case you didn't already know keeps
offers clinically proven treatments to
combat the symptoms of hair loss
treatments are delivered straight to
customers doors and plans are affordable
typically half the cost of Pharmacy
prices all treatment plans are
personalized and recommended by a
licensed medical provider because there
is no magic cure for baldness but if you
take action now the more hair you'll be
able to keep once you have picked your
plan and easily gotten it delivered with
your keeps treatment arriving at your
door every 3 6 or 12 months all you have
left to do is easily track progress and
experience less hair loss and hair
regrowth cubes comes to 24 7 expert
support in the form of an unlimited
on-demand access to a dedicated medical
provider this means that you can connect
with your medical provider about
anything anytime so whether you're
looking to prevent hair loss stimulate
hair growth or just take better care of
the hair you love keeps has you covered
especially considering two out of three
guys will experience hair loss by the
time they're 35. hair loss stops with
keeps to get special offer go to
keeps.com Alana Pierce or click the link
in the description that's ke ps.com
Alana Pierce and then the bottom for me
was Ubisoft and really that was just
because it was like such a weird
conference I'm really excited about
Prince of Persia I'm really happy to see
that style I think it looks awesome I'm
glad it's back in the way that it's back
apparently some people are mad about
that but it looks like it's like a
hollow Knight Ari type and I love those
games and it used to be like that right
Prince of Persia came from those roots I
think it looks awesome and it's
cool to see Ubisoft doing something
different break out of the Ubisoft
formula because otherwise it would just
be way too similar to Assassin's Creed
right so love it think it looks great
um I also think Star Wars Outlaws
looks good open world fatigue is going
to hit me there uh and I'm already such
a big fan of the Jedi series that yeah
I'm just not sure I want to play another
game in that Universe there's so much
Star Wars man there's just so much Star
Wars across the board I'm so tired of
Star Wars that's just me personally the
Disney stuff they just saturated that
market
um so I'm just not not sure if I wanna
play it but it does look good Assassin's
Creed Mirage looked terrible during the
presentation but when I watched gameplay
afterwards the graphics were way better
so they clearly just got unlucky with
the stream there nice to see Skull and
Bones vaguely represented where is
Beyond Good and Evil 2 who knows but
really it was just a really awkward
conference if you haven't seen the UB
self conferences I did put a reaction up
on my it's on my streams Channel I just
decided to do like the main conferences
here on my main channel the the scripts
were really weird the prompted stuff was
weird it was it was just
it felt like it like a 2013 E3
conference it was just really rough to
watch and I don't know why because
they've been doing so well recently like
all the conferences that
use of hosts
um the Ubisoft direct style like they're
just so good that I don't know why they
went back to agreement person and showed
us a bunch of mobile games like unless
it was in for investors and not for
gamers which is always totally possible
just a weird conference but overall the
main thing for me is that I had fun like
I love this time of year and I always
say that as soon as I stopped loving
this time of year then I should leave
the games industry
give up my spot to somebody else
it's just fun see new video games like I
love
streaming the shows and trying to guess
what's what you know like that stuff's
just it's just a good timing year okay
so I got a bunch of questions about
Ahmed core
six which I did get to see but I'm not
actually allowed to make any comment on
it yet
um the Embargo is up next week and I
already have a little podcast with some
other people who saw it planned to
hopefully go up either that day or the
day after but I will say
for any armored Core fans it continues
to be armored Core it's not Elder ring
It's Not Dark Souls it's armored Core
personally I love that and I love that
from soft you shouldn't have to just
make the same one genre it's still a
make action game um that's all I can say
that's it next question is oh man please
tell us what you got to see of Alan Wake
too yes the Embargo for that one is up
so we only got to see a little bit more
beyond what was shown in the showcase
for Alan week 2 a little bit of a boss
fight and more details on the Mind
Palace thing that they spoke about and
they've I think like very much nailed
the vibe of a survival horror for
remedies first survival horror game the
game looks scary as it has some
jump scares it has cheesy characters
um I will admit that I was not a huge
fan of saga's
um actress's voice performance I found
it to be kind of jarring and I think
part of that was that um correct me if
I'm wrong but I think she's almost
definitely not American and I
as
someone who also doesn't use a hard R in
any of my words kept catching that in
sentences and I found it very
distracting so I would guess she's
English or Australian or a kiwi
um but it did stand out to me as like
the one biggest negative for me is I
just wasn't a fan of her performance um
I feel like she was probably directed
that way because in theory she is a
character in Alan's book so if she's
speaking kind of more like a
melodramatic character it makes sense
but they were just and I'm not an
actress who what am I you know what am I
complaining about
there were just some line reads almost
all of them that I felt were um I don't
know just not really how a person would
actually say them you know very curious
how the mind Palace is going to work if
you didn't catch that it's basically
like this menu that I think you can go
to anytime to assess Clues uh which I
think is a really smart mechanic uh to
build into you know detective Thriller
survival horror it's kind of like your
safe room in Resident Evil even though
those kind of also exist
um in the game World actually but yeah
so you go into this place and and you
get to assess any clues that you found
people's faces pictures
um notes hints in general and I'm very
curious to see more of it or at least
try it myself because it was hard for me
to draw any kind of conclusion of like
how involved it'll actually be like does
it kind of solve the problems for you if
you click on the right thing or do you
have to like really make sure you piece
it out yourself I'm not sure the combat
looks like a dramatic improvement over
the first game still flashlight was used
um but everything's a lot faster from
the way that it looks not not anymore
awkward pausing while you hold a torch
on someone and the enemy animation was
mind-blowingly good looking incredible
in fact the all of the environments I
felt like were pretty well uh detailed
um at first Saga delt further into the
woods which is part of what we saw in
the trailer investigating the cult of
the tree so naturally you have to go
look at an area with some trees very
pretty a lot of density very open
looking environments though I'm sure
they'll uh
keep you on track pretty well which is
also going to be very interesting
because the thermoses
um also allow you to swap between
playing a saga and playing as Alan so
I'm really curious about how linear it's
actually going to be honestly I love
walking away from like a preview having
more questions than not oh and my
absolute favorite thing about it was
that they've so clearly learned from
control which I felt was a very visually
impressive and very visually creative
game this was such a visual Delight they
were like clearly leaning a pause
through the woods where you get um maybe
a city just flicker in an overlay sort
of with some opacity or transparency
over the top but overlaid so perfectly
that you would still know what direction
you're walking on because the pods mimic
each other like there was so much of
that and it was so cool to look at and
like I said just clearly an expansion on
what they learned in control it was so
impressive and I think the combat has
probably been improved by control as
well the tension looks really good
visual Fidelity all looks very good
um a lot of boxes ticked but still a lot
of questions so I can't tell you if it's
good or not I don't know I am excited to
learn more after a 13-year wait the
other one was cyberpunk Phantom Liberty
uh which I played for about 45 minutes I
did play the main quest which was
awesome and I tried to get to the point
where I would meet Idris elba's
character but unfortunately ran out of
time
um cyberpunk is Phantom Liberty is a
pretty massive overhaul for anyone who
wasn't aware in fact I don't feel like
they've been marketing it that way but
it certainly is that way they changed
the AI they changed some of the
structure
um AI did stuff in Phantom Liberty that
it never did in cyberpunk 2077. Grain
assault I always played that game on PC
I never played it on Console so I feel
like my experience was always very good
with cyberpunk you can go see my day one
stream still here on my channel where
it's like the game looked beautiful and
I didn't have many bugs and it was
always a huge fan but I'm sure press
probably did some interviews about
Phantom Liberty that I would recommend
going and reading because it seems like
it is like a much bigger expansion than
like just a story DLC which is kind of
the way they've been advertising it they
made some significant changes so if
you're interested in an updated version
of cyberpunk I would definitely
recommend reading up on some people's
maybe interviews for cdpr about it
because
yeah I feel like they've weirdly
undersold it maybe that's them learning
a lesson I don't know hey Lana just
wondering what you thought of the Final
Fantasy 16 event and the demo great to
see you on stage by the way well thank
you honored to be a part of it I'm so
excited about that game so I
actually decided I'm not going to play
the demo
um I know people saying it's incredible
I did watch some people play a little
bit of it but I decided not to even
though I know you keep you safe progress
because I didn't want to have to wait
I didn't want to play it play it and
then wait 10 days I'm fine to just wait
for the game to come out especially when
my whole like all my spare gaming hours
right now just being sunk into Diablo so
I decided not to I am extremely excited
about that game and about repo Final
Fantasy right now
popping off across the board every
single game they have right now
obviously 14 as well
um
killing it on that front but yeah uh I
got to be a part of the event in that I
was part of the
um a narrative panel which was awesome
two people whose work I really love and
respect obviously I was quite Limited in
the amount of questions I was allowed to
ask what I could ask because I sent them
a ton and then we spoke about which ones
you know I was going to to ask
on the day and I did get to ask about
you know um the comparisons to Game of
Thrones and they were like well yeah
they're a similarities Game of Thrones
but Game of Thrones also shouldn't get
to own this style and I totally agree
with that but I actually think it's
really exciting I don't think many games
have really tried to tackle that kind of
Storytelling the music was awesome it
looks awesome the combat looks awesome
um and as somebody who's been playing
Final Fantasy since like before I
actually knew what Final Fantasy was
nine is my favorite by the way but 16
looks to be making some very big changes
I'm very excited and I'm excited to see
how I like them yeah the game I walked
away the most excited about is Starfield
if we remove Starfield I think that game
33 scavengers I think it was called
really blew my mind it was like okay
it's like a Hades
sort of Bastion sort of thing with 33
player co-op oh my God
and I'm really excited about Prince of
Persia I had no idea that was going to
be there it looks awesome so yeah all in
all a lovely time of year I still intend
to catch up on uh the rgg Showcase from
today because I'm my love Yakuza slash
like a dragon would love to find out a
little bit more about the games that
they uh announced less revealed and I
was also going to catch up on the Xbox
extended showcase which I will also just
do live on Twitch when I get a chance
and the accessibility showcase so not
caught up on everything I'm gonna skip
the PC gaming show and the wholesome
direct let me know if the comments have
been making a bad decision and I should
watch those too they were both pretty
long only so much time in the day I
heard the PC gaming showcase wasn't
great
but um yeah if there are any really cool
things that you guys saw there I'd be
happy to catch up on this that is it for
me today everyone I will see you all
next month huge thanks to keep
sponsoring the video as always I'm Alana
see you guys next time like